Hey Dandelion,
how's it going?
Hey,
I'm doing pretty well and yourself pretty good.
Do you mind if I asked you 67 questions?
Go for it.
So rush.
Cool.
How'd you get into work today?
Woke up,
spent a,
I spent about a half an hour sort of enjoying company with the people I live
with and then drove
favorite part of the tensorflow staff?
Well I would have to say tensor boards since that's the case that I work on.
Favorite thing about working at Google?
There are a lot of different things I like about working at Google.
I think the thing that's most important to me is that I feel that Google as an
organization really cares about the impact it has on the world.
And so I've been in a lot of meetings where we've kind of been able to think
about how to deploy some technology that could help people.
And the conversation is always first like how can we do something that's useful?
And then the question of how will we make money is like,
ah,
you know,
let's do something important first.
And we can always figure that out later.
How would you describe your experience at Palentier?
Uh,
I would say I learned a lot and grew a lot as a developer.
If you could spend an evening,
Rick,
one famous person,
who would it be?
If I could spend an evening,
uh,
maybe Barack Obama.
You play any sports?
No.
Do you miss being a student?
I miss having such an abundance of people like living close by to me who I knew
in good socially interact with.
But on the whole I really like being employed as a software engineer.
What's your favorite fan?
It's really difficult to choose a single favorite band.
Uh,
I would say my favorite music is like very danceable fusion tunes.
and as I sort of like organized by genre rather than brand.
Is there a programming language you really don't like it?
You know,
I've never been too fond of Java.
It seems like it really has a lot of boiler plate.
Uh,
and I often,
I often have a love hate relationship with Java script and that I wish it had
like static typing and a couple others.
Nice.
Maybe more consistent semantics programming,
language of choice for machine learning.
Uh,
it would have to be python since that's the Lingua Franca of machine learning.
And of course the tensorflow frontend is written in python.
Favorite professor.
I had a professor named Larry Mckenna niece at u Chicago and he was the head of
the writing department.
And my conversations with him really shaped the way that I think.
How are you liking the Bayer?
I love living in the bay.
It's beautiful.
It has a lot of like fun,
weird people.
It's got a lot of great dancing.
It's got a lot of great piking.
Why do you choose to work on a,
on a,
I think that it's going to be really,
it has the potential to really impact a lot of people and it offers the
opportunity to like help create societies in which people are freer in which
there's more abundance.
And I'd like to be a part of that.
What's the most beautiful thing in the room?
It's difficult to choose single most beautiful things,
but as a pattern,
I refined it really fascinating how the world seems to self organize and to
these complex ecosystems and fractals and so forth.
So maybe the tendency of the world towards emerging self organization is the
thing I find most beautiful.
Last thing you made with your hands.
I have this floating light bulb,
sort of a piece of art.
Uh,
it has a,
an electromagnet and the base that suspends a light bulb above it.
And my friend Chaz and I took it apart and sort of redid the design.
So we switched it from having a really like polished modern look into a sort of
a grungy industrial wood.
And that was a fun project.
Robin,
do you miss your hometown town?
I prefer the bay area.
What website do you waste time on Facebook.
You get an all expenses paid trip to one city where you go,
uh,
probably is tenable.
But if I could time travel,
I would want to go back to Rome.
At the peak of Roman Empire,
would you visit Mars?
It depends on the terms and conditions and transit time.
And who else is there and what's going on.
What is one thing you can't live without
connection to other humans?
What was it like presenting at the tensorflow Dev Summit?
Uh,
it was pretty fun.
I really liked the content and I was really happy to get to share knowledge
about 10 board with the central floor community.
What text editor do you use?
I've been switching between sublime text and Adam.
Uh,
I was kind of excited about the fact that Adam is open source by find sublime
has better performance.
So I kind of haven't quite stabilized on one or the other.
What open source library you really like tensorflow?
What's one of your favorite movies?
I really like V for vendetta.
I really like the network.
I really like Kenneth Brown,
his rendition of Hamlet.
Uh,
I saw Vicky,
Cristina Barcelona recently.
I thought it was great.
What inspired you to focus on deep learning?
Specific,
the whims of fate.
What was the first program you ever made in eighth grade?
I made a little program for calculating time numbers.
What is one book you really like?
Well,
there's so many books.
Uh,
if I have to choose one,
then it's like a really like I want to choose something quite good.
I really liked,
there's a book called Poor Charlie's Almanack and it's written by Charlie
Munger,
who's Warren Buffet's investment partner and it's sort of a collection of
aphorisms describing how he approaches living life.
Uh,
and I found that that to be really interesting.
Oh,
and I love Godel Escher Bach,
one of my favorite,
one of my favorite books that I've only read half of it.
And if I were to say books that I've only read the introduction,
I would say Bertrand Russell's a history of western philosophy.
What's the bravest thing you've ever done?
I don't know.
If you were a Greek God,
who would it be?
Athena,
what is one piece of advice you'd give yourself 10 years ago?
Oh wait,
maybe I would choose like mercury or Hermes,
a one piece of advice that I would give myself 10 years ago.
Focus less on the intellect and you remember that not all truth is arrived at
spruce thinking.
What is a topic in machine learning you'd like to explore more?
I think there's a huge potential for using machine learning,
for creating tools,
for augmenting human creativity.
So for example,
I'd like to get to a point where you can like doodle a cartoon,
storyboard it and then have machine learning,
transform it into a finished cartoon with like voice acting and animation and
consistent design.
And I think that's a point where we might reach in the next uh,
two years.
Do you think will solve intelligence in your lifetime?
I have no idea.
If you were in the world,
what is one log you do that
I think if I ran the world I would try to your up better systems of government,
like maybe having better voting systems so that we don't get the situation where
people are all voting for the candidate.
They at least dislike because I think that that candidate has like the best shot
of winning the election.
Who is one person you looked up to when you were in college?
Warren Buffet.
What were you like as a kid in grade school?
I liked to read books and I would kind of hang out by myself and also play video
games.
What's something that excites you about the future?
I'm excited by the idea that we can learn to have a society that's kind of more
nurturing to people and focus less on competition and winning and more on like,
like expressing oneself and supporting and connecting with other humans.
If you were to start from scratch today,
what is one resource you would use to learn machine mark?
I really like Chris Olah is a blog which is see yola dot get hub.io and uh,
that would be,
that would be a starting point for me.
What is one major unsolved research problem you'd love to tackle?
There's a lot of different things here,
like transfer learning,
unsupervised learning.
Uh,
I'm not sure.
I'm not really a researcher.
Probably learning too develop a model architectures or learning to come up with
the right machine learning model.
What's more interesting?
Generative models or discriminative models?
Generative.
If you can be a superhero,
would it be
maybe iron man?
Although I would,
I think that the best,
the superhero with the best power is as document hadn't.
What's your spirit animal?
A alliance favorite computer scientist.
Jeff Dean.
If you had a time machine,
when would you visit?
So it depends if I'm visiting to check it out or visiting to say if I were
visiting to check it out like Rome at the height of empire,
assuming that I were fluent in Latin,
uh,
visiting.
Just stay.
I think maybe like living in a hunter gatherer society can be quite nice.
You actually use Google plus?
No.
Android or iPhone.
I have an iPhone.
What would surprise people about life at Google?
I was really surprised by this scope and raw power of Google infrastructure.
Uh,
I know it was pleasantly,
so I was,
I was pleasantly satisfied by how polite and friendly people are.
Favorite Linux distro?
I don't have one.
Have you ever been in love?
Yes.
Have you built an app with machine learning that you use in your day to day
life?
Nope.
All right.
Then that's it for my 67 questions.
Cool.
All right.
Have a good one.